welcome back to Piers Morgan uncensored
me Rosanna Lockwood you might notice but
change 13 million peers I'm standing in
all week pleasure to be with you now we
are revisiting this story that appears
to this fascinating interview or last
week I'm sure you saw it tick tock
Menace Missy he's the young man who
performs pranks on the general public
before uploading them to social media he
is very much back in trouble again
remanded in custody at the weekend for
reportedly breaching a court order not
to film members of the public without
their consent this is the video here of
his arrest now this new arrest took
place just a few days after Missy whose
real name by the way is bakari
bronzagaro he took part in an exclusive
and fiery interview with peers on this
very show in this very Studio he gave us
then some insight into why he continues
to create a havoc you've only got a tiny
fine today no deterrent to you
whatsoever you don't show any real
remorse you don't really care it is
the UK laws are weak simple as and
that's not my fault
which begs the question does Missy have
a point
a little you can all squeak simple as
should the criminal justice system deal
with young offenders harsher and earlier
than it currently does or is it fit for
purpose joining me to debate all of this
mizzy's friend fellow Tick Tock star
Billy the goat who spoke to the
prankster in the days leading up to his
arrest also joining us there from Norway
of all places criminal Barrister Casey
Chris door and here in the studio I'm
joined by talk TV contributor Esther
Krakow thanks so much Esther I'll come
back to you shortly but first let's get
over to Billy uh shall we because
Billy's mate he's the mate of mizzy so
you're able to talk to us first hand
about your knowledge of mizzy
um last we knew he's remanded back in
custody again have you checked in with
Missy and how he's doing
[Music]
I've spoken to him and I feel like my
interview kind of brought a different
side of him there like Pierce's one did
against you so that's why I'm that's why
I might have come across to the outside
world that were mates but I wouldn't say
it with mates but definitely someone
that like definitely someone I don't
waste any harm on him all right you saw
that interview did with peers then
um what did you make of it because I
know it went pretty viral a lot of
people saw it did you get much reaction
uh from people you knew how did they
think Missy performed
if I'm being honest with you I feel like
the interview went exactly how I
expected it to go to like I don't really
know what anyone anyone expected like he
brought like a prankster that's like a
in on that one of the big like a like a
professional TV show like I didn't
expect them to actually have any proper
dialogue if I'm being honest with you
and another thing is like I don't know I
feel like with there's a certain way you
talk to people I'm trying to say like
you don't you don't speak to everyone
the same way like obviously I understand
his own interviewing style but I feel
like sometimes according to who you're
interviewing you kind of have to change
up a little bit on the me person I don't
think he handled the music thing well
but then again I don't really blame him
because Missy Missy is a lot to handle
for being honest with you
I did meet Missy in the makeup room he
is a character look I appears isn't here
to defend himself he has got his own
interviewing style this is his show and
he's kind enough to put me in the seat
tonight uh to speak to you but let's
just talk about the punishment side of
it because that's what we're going to
talk to our next guests about as well uh
Missy said that the UK laws were weak
and I just want to go back to Billy uh
do you think Mrs right to say they're
weak because he's currently remanded in
custody
obviously that's his opinion me
personally like I've never had any
accounts with the system like I wouldn't
be able to give a firsthand opinion
whether the week or not but obviously
the public opinion was that lacker I
think it was like 350 pound finally got
and the public opinion is that that is
like a bit of a like a get off but at
the same time when you really look at a
situation like I don't I don't know I
would I wouldn't say that it's weak but
then again it depends which angle you
want to look at it though it depends I'm
going to look at it because realistic is
like I don't know what the exact loss I
don't know what the punishment is are
for each round really silly so I
couldn't say whether the week or not to
business I don't know so uh coming to
Esther in the studio the the
the idea behind this is that mizzy feels
uh somehow licensed to behave the way he
does because the laws are so weak I mean
that is what he said to peers you and I
were watching it from the studio he was
saying look at the UK laws are weak I'm
just gonna have my fun I don't care if
it's negative or positive I just want
engagement so do we need to change the
UK system
um yes obviously but I think it's it's a
combination of two different things this
is clearly an example of extremely bad
parenting and there's only so much that
the penal system can actually Rectify in
that situation this is a kid who is
hungry for attention and that's what the
social media era we're living in um is
clearly feeding him so he has no
boundaries obviously the deterrent
should have been more than a 350 pound
fine I'm assuming the judge thought that
he didn't actually have that money to
pay it or something I don't know but I
think that's clearly very weak he's
terrorizing the public but it is bad
parenting I often said you know there's
a reason why he's stealing old women's
puppies and jumping on uh conservative
Jewish men's backs he's not going to you
know tall black men in Tottenham because
he knows he probably won't go home with
all his teeth in his mouth
um so clearly it's it's a discipline
issue it's something that falls on his
parents quite squarely on the shoulders
but it's also a penal system issue and I
think we need to address both he's
obviously an example of what happens
when parenting goes very very wrong and
look we don't have mizzy here to talk
about his parents uh Billy says he's not
close enough to know uh Missy's family
but on the penal system side things
let's get over to Chris adore Casey
joining us from Norway and the reason
that you're in Norway Chris to my
understanding is to learn a little bit
about how they deal with youth crime
there so why do they get it better than
here
well because first of all um when they
when you're talking about young
teenagers they don't criminalize young
teenagers in Norway at all and indeed
there are other countries that don't
criminalize people until they're 18
years of age and the reason for that is
because as I think mizzy demonstrated
pretty clearly in his interview with
peers
um young people and particularly young
men don't really mature properly until
they're into their 20s and and the level
of immaturity that you could see in that
interview I think was clear for all to
see and frankly um when I watched Mrs
interview I thought that the whole thing
was him playing around with Piers Morgan
rather than the other way around it
rather looked like he had kind of um
managed to get one over on Piers quite a
lot of that interview because ultimately
Mrs objective is very clear isn't it to
get as much attention as he can and
that's not dissimilar or I would have
would suggest from television presenters
and media stars of every different
generation and every age it is about
attention seeking clearly some of the
things he's done are um you know are are
very unpleasant to the people involved
but you know we've had these kind of
prank TV shows on television for years
and years and years will remember in the
80s there were programs where people
were had their cars crushed and they had
no idea what was going on and they
didn't consent to that in the first
place and and you know so so is it a
genre that is only available to
middle-aged white presenters because it
does feel a little bit like it we've got
an 18 year old who's capturing a lot of
attention a lot about audience um and
and really I I think it's all the storm
in a teacup yeah it will Chris I'm
interested you saying that because I'm
with you on a lot of TV personalities
pushing the envelope as far as they can
to generate engagement not caring about
negativity let's just get attention but
there's one thing doing that pushing the
envelope there's another thing
illegality we've got some videos of
mesozantics we can remind viewers of
breaking into people's houses stealing
people's dogs uh leapfrogging over
people on the street you know just
pretty bad anti-social uh Behavior stuff
but also some actual sort of pretty bad
criminal acts you've got walking into
people's houses and things like that you
know this is what has landed him in a
lot of trouble with police so could you
really say this is on a par Chris uh you
know with I don't know Jeremy Beadle and
people back in the day it's exactly on a
part with it because the people who were
subject of those pranks didn't get have
any consent uh their friends set them up
or their family set them up for it and
and so I don't I honestly don't see the
difference it's it's a situation where
people are taking advantage of other
people to create content which many many
young people in particular on Tick Tock
find funny and so I just think you know
he's 18 years of old old he's quite
immature when you talk about criminal
acts I mean you know it's on the margins
of criminality some of this stuff as
opposed to anything that would be
particularly serious I suspect
eventually he'll grow out of it
um as most young people do provided
they're not locked up in prison because
this is really where Norway have got it
right they don't lock people up in
prison and they don't look um at young
people up in prison unless they've done
something really bad a really extreme
violence uh and long-term criminality
and and if you lock teenagers up the one
thing you guarantee is when they come
out of custody as this young man will
I'm sure within days or a few weeks when
they come out of custody they are more
criminalized than when they went to it
so if we're going to have this idea that
we need to lock people up for longer and
get tough and all this stuff you end up
with more crime in society as opposed to
the sort of peaceful place we have here
in Oslo where there's a 3 000 pound
barbecue it's not even locked up they
just leave it here on the side of the uh
on on the side of the water because no
one's going to steal it and why is that
it's not because they're getting tough
and cracking down on young offenders
it's because they do the opposite yeah
you're not going to see that and the
Streets of London Manchester Birmingham
anywhere around the UK really that three
thousand pound bob I want to come back
to Billy uh while we've got you Billy
and some of those points that Chris made
about entertainment this is just
entertainment it's just Tick Tock you
know do you think it's okay what Missy
is doing to these people for
entertainment
nah definitely not obviously if you
watch the interview are done with him
like I made it clear that I don't
condone anything done but at the same
time though like to answer a question I
really you know it's not okay but then
to add some context I feel like similar
to what he was saying before like we are
in an everywhere it's all about shock
factors all about attention even though
I do um internet and I do make content
myself I did understand that there is
repercussions with just doing anything
everything for Visa I'm trying to say to
you I'm busy being I promise so me
personally life I also like I don't know
advise any up and coming content
creators I would definitely say that
don't you feel the need to like do
whatever comes to your mind that's going
to get infused like actually think of
black a legacy and try and build a
sustainable internet City like running
people's houses and taking books that's
not sustainable that's like you can only
do that one to two three times and then
there's nothing you can do after that
again trying to say yeah I think it's
actually very smart it isn't sustainable
at all it's one and done uh the Esther
will give you the final word on this
um the solution to this you know we're
hearing Chris say you don't like people
up unnecessarily if it's not too
criminal I mean could you agree with
that what's the solution for someone
like Missy it depends on what you define
as two criminal I'm sure if that was his
mother that he had a young group of men
breaking into a house uh he would feel a
bit more different differently about
what is too criminal uh the reality is
there needs to be a deterrent in place
because what you see happening now is
because something like this is getting
mizzy the attention that he wants and
the attention that he craves you push
the envelope and more people are
incentivized to push the envelope today
they're entering people's houses
tomorrow they're doing something even
more and generally terrifying the
general public I made the point that if
he was in a different country if it was
in the US for instance they would
actually have the right to shoot him
um so you know how far is too far before
someone seriously gets hurt it's not
just about the fact that you don't think
that what they've done is particularly
criminal it's also about the fact that
how Justified would someone be to react
in a way that is generally in you know
in pursuit of preserving their own life
as they see you know as being threatened
and so I think it's something to not
take lightly and I think people that do
take it lightly don't understand the
wise The Wider societal context and the
issue here with just bad parenting as
well